welcome back to glamour unfiltered
hosted by me Josh Smith and today we're
joined by McQueen it's Meghan Trainor
honey how are you we are running new
album is out yes suite myself
treat yourself what is Meghan Trainor
3.0 who is she she is older I don't know
I've learned so much about things I did
not know about like anxiety and in how
life goes like this
I understand now yeah I see it and now
we're coming back up and I'm very happy
and I'm I have the love of my life who's
like number one how do you think finding
the love of your life has helped you
it's crazy because when I was going
through like my surgery and I was just
dating him it was like very early on
dating and I was like okay so nice to
get to know you I have to be silent for
like a month and a half and it was very
frustrating if like we ever if I was
furious or like I wanted to say
something but I couldn't and I would
just get so upset and then I would get
in my head and and think like oh I'm
never gonna be a singer ever again it's
crazy cuz I'm like I got to love my life
I have a beautiful home I have a great
career but I went I still went into this
dark place of terror it turns out it was
anxiety how did you what do you think
you learn about yourself in that period
time life I need to ask for more help
and I need to speak up because I the
schedule is crazy and not a lot of
people see what your schedule is hmm my
voice I know it can't handle it and we
would talk about it but I still had to
get another surgery like I felt like I
failed because I pushed myself too far I
sang too many shows I was doing radio
shows after a whole tour and I needed
surgery and I was like how did I get
here again it's only been a year no see
you've been talking quite a bit about
social anxiety and anxiety in itself how
long have you had it for my dad was like
you've always been a little worried
I'm always like but Dad would if my
whole life I got but I never had the
physical reactions my second surgery a
few years ago like maybe three years ago
in the beginning of this album I was
having like vibrations or I'd have like
I'd be burning up and I'm like I have a
fever today and each day was a new like
a new thing like one day my back felt
like it was on fire and I was like oh
man I think I'm going crazy and I went
to the emergency room a couple times cuz
I was like I'm allergic to this food and
my throat's closing and they were like
oh sweetheart it's just your brain and
you're like no no look I'm like no it's
real but the psychiatrist told me like
your chemicals are off you're like this
and we gotta get you back to this and I
was like that's the first thing that
ever made sense to me thank you so much
I went on medicine and it like I asked
for a very low dose I was like I don't
want to change or anything and it did it
didn't change me at all and except for
help my panic and I haven't had panic
attacks since everyone has this little
stigma against it but my doctor said to
me why can you use an inhaler for your
lungs but you can't use medicine for
your brain and I was like never brother
brother base shirt right yeah I mean
there's a lot of power in talking and
sharing about your experience yeah I
know for me I heard like Carson Daly he
did a whole segment and and explained
what happened to him in a panic attack
and my parents haven't really had one or
they couldn't really understand they're
like don't gonna burn serum like that's
so much money just come over here and
we'll rub your head I'm like I need an
oxygen tank or I'm gonna die like
tonight and Carson Daly explained it
perfectly and I sent that video to my
mom and she like was bawling and was
like I didn't know this is what you felt
and now I understand because you can't
like explain what's happening except for
like I'm dying I'm dying I'm pretty sure
I'm dying and so that was like so
helpful and made me feel like oh I'm not
alone at all like he helped me if I can
speak up about it and tell people so
they don't feel alone and like superb
I'm down to talk about it what's it feel
like in that moment when it happens
dad I don't know it feels like we were
on a boat the other night and we were
all dizzy because I was doing a private
gig trying to make that money and we we
were rocking and it's and I was like
this is the beginning of a panic attack
but for me and then I get my throat
closes and then I'm certain that I can't
breathe and I'm like this is how I'm
gonna die like right here right now just
panicking I remember in the very
beginning when I would try to learn
about it
I would watch this video and just
hearing about it I fell over and was
like full panic it was like oh I just
triggered myself then I learned you
could trigger yourself I was like like
the world was a terrifying place and now
there's no surprise oh my god I was
trapped or trapped my doctors like at
least you don't you're not stuck in your
house and like you relate a room to a
panic I'm like oh I do I can't sleep in
my bedroom right now because that's
where I have panic attacks and I would
change out my whole house to be like
we're sleeping in here now cuz it's a
new day a new room I'm fine like that's
what we were trying to do to switch
things up I had to help
Daryl my husband I had to teach him like
here's what I need you to do in these
moments I need you to not be like are
you okay are you okay what's wrong talk
to me I'm like nope just tell me that
I'm breathing in that everything's fine
and rub my back and shut up what's also
helped you apart from the medicine
talking about it and my husband and I
are like we're very we're trying to be
very positive we used to write down like
five things were grateful for every day
and I just got lazy he's still writing
his journal but moments like that where
he's like look up look how awesome this
is and he would sing to me like out of
ki this terrible song we wrote that's
like we they're the best laughs and we
would try to sing it with each other and
yeah so I think having my best friend
with me my family with me everywhere I
go is mandatory do you think this
experience is maingi more grateful for
the success that you've had it kind of
made me forgot about all of it
was sad almost the time I don't feel
successful and I don't feel like I did
it but like dr. Phil interviewed me and
he started with all the things I've
accomplished and I was like so I was
like oh my god he's like yeah that's a
lot I was like I forgot about all of
that like I've been stuck in right now
what am i doing right now and that's not
the point is it like I have to remember
all the amazing moments that happened
and and realize why I get to do what I
get to do yeah because I mean you become
for so many people such a celebration of
this much-lauded term self-love and it's
difficult to learn to love yourself
right
how have you learn to love yourself um
to champion yourself as a weird thing
but it's like no we everyone should be
like Kobe you know and I'm just trying
to get that message out of like you're a
lot to like love yourself in yeah and
you know be your favorite person I'll be
your best friend your best friend doc
dr. Phil oh yeah yeah dr. Phil was like
the way you talk about yourself would
you ever say those things to your best
friend and I was like I was like no I
would never say those things cuz they're
so mean and then I was like oh my god
I'm so mean to myself I'm my biggest
bully mmm like you know when you're in a
room and you think everyone's talking
about you or you're like I'm sure
they're paranoid and stuff it's just you
being your worst enemy yes your hat
nobody cares because everyone is
obsessed with themselves in a way yeah
well I learned that I go to like events
now in parties now and I'm like I don't
give a what like I just enjoy and I I
did it the other night and I had the
best time yeah one of the things you
said to me the other day when we were
talking is I remember this because I
thought about it for quite a while
afterwards when you were saying that you
were like dancing on stage singing all
about that bass and everyone was like
yes honey she's feeling herself but
inside you want feeling yourself yeah in
the beginning in the very beginning
because I wrote that song as like I wish
this was on the radio I could really use
it and then like songs like that weren't
on the radio so when I was told I'm
gonna sing
I was like okay it's not like really how
I feel
I've been insecure my whole life but
like how fun would it be if I felt like
this and when I would perform it the
crowd would go wild
especially when I did booty back that
was my moment I was like I had never
danced in front of people like imagine
shaking my butt in front of this entire
crowd and they're screaming like
praising it I'm like wow like that'll
get anyone confident that was the best
therapy I could have ever asked for
what how's your relationship with your
body and your South change it's great
we're friends now yeah especially with
my husband we're all about like we want
a sea of children we want many kids and
we want to live till we're 120 so the
goal is to live long and be healthy so
we work out and we try to eat as healthy
as we can but we'll like spoil ourselves
treat ourselves every now and then with
some pizza nicki minaj the other day
told me that she loved my butt and i was
like oh my world
she's like you got a great ass and i
live off your leash like that is going
on my team's time I was like oh I'm good
life is complete
yeah so I've been very confident lately
but yeah I'll have my days where I'll be
like this hotel don't tell them where
but like mirrors every way yeah where
they don't need to be in the bathroom
when you're sitting down to be there's
mirror you're like no I do not need to
see this reflected by yeah yeah but my
husband usually will catch me maybe like
hey stop that
you're amazing you're gorgeous tell
yourself and I'm like damn easing you're
going in the mirror oh yeah cuz when you
hear that all those bad thoughts yeah
let go away yeah would you say you've
learned to let go yeah what's that been
like for you to be able to let go and
it's like a switch I have of like I just
don't care what people think right now
and it's it's like one of the most
impossible things to do is like
obviously did not care
and I care about whatever on things but
like sometimes like instead of having
social anxiety or wanting to curl up in
a ball and leave early and cry I'm like
no I'm gonna enjoy myself for these few
hours and I'm gonna shine and I was like
the light of the party I was dancing
when people were sitting and I was like
I don't care what anyone thinks if you
could sit the you down who started off
in this music industry
you can sit her down right here right
now I'm her weight my 19 year olds yeah
what would you want us to 8 to her don't
worry everything's gonna be amazing and
even when it's not amazing something
great will come out of that like even
when you feel really depressed and you
got your second surgery you're gonna
have the love of your life they're
rubbing your feet and making sure that
you're okay and your family gets better
and better and they'll all live around
he's very soon
I'm like about so powerful honey amazing
I was so alone at 19 you know anymore no
I didn't get to have my family there are
you gonna cry I feel like I'm actually
shaking I was like not really man I
shoulda grinded like I was like whoa I
was looking into my soul yeah you were
there I thought like I was actually like
19 year old you in there well I think
you're amazing I love you love you thank
you babe is this it
[Music]